now to Iran where President Hassan
rouhani has called on the United States
to end its policy of maximum pressure
and urged Washington to return to
dialogue logic and reason
speaking in New York a day after address
in the United Nations President rouhani
also said he would be prepared to hold
talks if President Trump lifted
sanctions against Iran DWS Alexandra for
Norman spoke with US Special
Representative for Iran Brian Hawk and
asked him about Washington's strategy
the US government has imposed new
sanctions and travel restrictions on the
Iranian regime but Tehran seems to
remain defiant so it's you maximum
pressure strategy not working no we're
very pleased with it and we're also very
pleased here at the United Nations this
week that Germany France and the United
Kingdom have announced that we need a
new nuclear deal that is much more
comprehensive than the Iran nuclear deal
that the United States left last year
the Iran nuclear deal failed to cover
Iran's missile program in fact it
relaxed constraints on Iran's missile
program and now here today we see the
consequences in the Middle East with
Iran using missiles to attack Saudi
Arabia so we think this was a very
productive and good week with our
European friends they all said that Iran
is behind the attack on Saudi Arabia so
I think the press has overstated our
differences and I think the announcement
this week is an example of that however
as you said tensions have been rising
recently so are we getting closer to a
major conflict
I don't think so that really is a
question for Iran we are committed to
resolving our differences with Iran
diplomatically the problem is that Iran
is answering our diplomacy with military
force and I think what they did against
Saudi Arabia meets the definition of an
act of war so it's what what I saw this
week at the UN our nation's increasingly
diplomatically isolating Iran for
behaving like an outlaw state that
doesn't respect basic international
norms France and Germany are trying to
mediate between the u.s. and Iran to
facilitate at
rocks are you willing to embrace their
help well we have made clear from the
President on down that we are very much
opened to talks with the Iranians they
continue to say no and so Iran faces a
choice they can either come to the
negotiating table and work out our
differences diplomatically or they can
watch their economy collapse as our
sanctions intensify they wants you to
lift some sanctions is it going to
happen I think the burden is on Iran to
demonstrate that it has reached a change
of heart and we had attacks in Saudi
Arabia only a week or two ago and so I
think what the world should be asking is
not whether the United States is going
to lift its pressure but when will Iran
stop using military force instead of
diplomacy thank you so much okay thanks
for having me on